vous ne portez pas une part de
responsabilité comme tous les ministres
de la santé dont je fais partie des gens
extrêmement humble et qui pensent que
bien évidemment j'aurais eu tout soeur
depuis le premier jour de ma vie mieux
quand on voit la gestion de cette crise
est une gestion d'urgence le constat est
plutôt catastrophique pour un pays comme
la france
lorsqu'on est dans une guerre ne
reconnaît au front il y était question
qu'on peut se poser
il ya des questions que se posera plus
tard parce que c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire comme on n'en voit jamais
personne n'aurait pu penser que nous
serions aujourd'hui nouveau je vous
parle en saturation des lits de
réanimation en seine-saint-denis a quasi
saturation sur l'île de france
la seule chose qui peut compter
maintenant c'est le confinement le
dépistage et le traitement et j'espère
que ce confinement sera remarquablement
fait parce que là la différence en
confinement moyennement fait et un
confinement très bien fait c'est des
centaines de lits drea à l'assemblée
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour 1h30 émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités tenus à bonne distance
évidemment et nos reporters sur le
terrain une émission essentiellement
consacrée à la crise du coronavirus en
france et dans le monde
déconfinement adapté par territoire mais
pas par région distanciation sociale et
port du masque qui sera probablement
obligatoire dans les transports publics
voici les grandes lignes du plan de
déconfinement présenté par emmanuel
macron aux élus locaux
l'exécutif qui dément une nouvelle
polémique selon radio france des
respirateurs fabriqué en urgence serait
inadapté aux malades du corps d'un virus
la course européenne au vaccin contre le
coc u19 s'intensifient à londres et à
berlin qui lance aujourd'hui des essais
cliniques
les vingt sept charges la commission de
présenter un fonds de relance d'ici le 6
mai annonce des manuels macron ce soir
qui appelle à aller plus loin plus fort
vers la souveraineté européenne
[Musique]
de la vigilance toujours encore plus
face aux ports aux navires us et
services de renseignement sont
pleinement mobilisés si paiera taxe d
information organisée volumes échangés
sur internet
les menaces ne faiblissent pas dans
l'ombre des hommes veille et pendant que
le gouvernement organise lui la lutte
face à cette situation inédite de
pandémie les prix de pétrole négatif
l'incroyable s'est produit cette semaine
avec la chute à - 37 dollars du baril de
brut américain un plongeon historique
l'excès d'offre sur le marché est telle
que certains sont prêts à payer pour
pour les débarrassent de leur production
alors comment en est on arrivé là
peut-on l'expliquer par la seule crise
du coronavirus le secteur pétrolier
peut-il s'en relever autant de questions
qu'elle l'économiste jacques sapir
tentera de répondre dans sa chronique à
21h15 ce soit
[Musique]
comment va se dérouler la près 11 mai si
l'exécutif planche toujours sur le plan
de déconfinement l'elysée a donné
quelques précisions à l'issue d'une
réunion entre emmanuel macron et les
élus ont fait le point avec estelle
farges
il avait un temps été évoqué le
déconfinement région par région
l'exécutif semble avoir finalement
balayé cette piste c'est ce qu'a indiqué
à l'elysée à l'issue d'une réunion entre
emmanuel macron et des a's élus locaux
indé confinement qui devra toutefois
être adapté à la réalité un de chaque
territoire l'elysée qui a esquissé ce
jeudi les principaux axes de la praye 11
mai concernant le retour des élèves en
classe il devrait se faire sur la base
du volontariat départ en cette rentrée
elle sera progressive avec une priorité
donnée aux enfants à les plus en
difficulté aux enfants les plus jeunes
ceux à qui ne sont pas autonomes des
précisions aussi sur le port du masque
qu'il faudra probablement imposé dans
les transports publics les masques ffp2
eux resteront en priorité à destination
à des soignants les maires qui sont
encouragés à acheter massivement des
masques grand public
mais l'exécutif entend rester en sur une
logique de recommandations un dernier
mot enfin sur le calendrier emmanuel
macron et qui s'est engagé à ce qu' a
les grands lignes de l'après 11 mai soit
présenté en début de semaine prochaine
aux élus locaux pour pouvoir échanger
avec eux sur ce point et puis il faudra
attendre début mai avant que le plan de
déconfinement ne soit présenté dans son
intégralité
et pour parler de ceux des confinement
qui s'esquisse peu à peu nous sommes
avec renaud muselier est président l air
de la région sub provence alpes côte
d'azur et présidents de régions de
france bonsoir renaud muselier merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors pas de déconfinement régionaliser
mais adaptée au territoire sachant votre
région est pas remis
les moins touchés en termes de
contamination quand on compare
évidemment avec d'autres régions comme
l'ile-de-france où l'alsace est ce que
vous craignez un afflux de vacanciers
partir du virus cet été et beaucoup de
questions mais en question alors hein
nous nous avons toujours demandé un
calendrier une méthode et une approche
différenciée est donc là dedans ce que
nous avons opposé tout à l'heure au
premier ministre avec lady charlize qui
l'accompagné nous voulons un seul côté
confie les blancs le même pour tous avec
une intensité qu'il soit variable en
fonction des territoires
ça veut dire quoi on a une carte
nationale et après on peut qu'il sera
fixé et j'espère semaine prochaine est
on prêt après travailler au niveau local
ça veut dire quoi
effectivement notre région consacre déjà
plutôt moins touchée que tant mieux mais
même dans la région il ya des disparités
les alpes-de-haute-provence n'ont pas la
même densité des 10 buts et que les
bouches-du-rhône les alpes-maritimes
on n'a pas donc mettre des barrières
elle train régional ou être à
départementale ça n'a aucun sens par
contre nous qui allons charge les
transports
les transports interurbains et les
lycées nous avons la capacité de
réouvrir tout ça en bonhomme est en
bonne forme
parallèlement à ça l'autre volet qui a
été abordé sur le plan de la crise
économique qui catastrophiques sur le
tourisme sur le plan du tourisme
regardez vous à nos amis corses qui sont
juste en face de nous ils sont 2 x glide
puits contaminés que nous est ce qu'on
ne doit pas les points on va pas parler
on va pas échanger
m on va couper les ferries ont peu à
corser et et nice toulouse marseille n'a
pas de sens la réalité c'est que
aujourd'hui notre économie est à plat on
a perdu 4 milliards d'euros dans la
région provence alpes côte d'azur dans
le mois qui vient d'arriver avec nous
ôter jamais le camping fermé avec une
aubade aux hôtels restaurants nous
voulons avoir la doctrine pour la
réouverture des bars à midi aux joies
des terrasses ouvertes et avait
d'ailleurs impossible ou non et on
s'adaptera avec une seule donnée
absolument indispensable
c'est la distanciation la distanciation
et se laver les mains
mais ça on celle organisée il ya que les
locaux qui peuvent le faire et on va le
faire au niveau régional de l'asra
territoire en territoire alors autres
information avec cette esquisse de
déconfinement le retour à l'école le 11
mai prochain qui se fera finalement sur
la base du volontariat c'est plus adapté
selon vous à certains parents inquiets
notamment de toute façon maintenant je
retrouver la liberté
il faut trouver il faut sortir de ce
soir il faut y aller en chargeant ses
habitudes faut-il être masqué je pense
que oui dès que vous êtes à moins d'un
mètre cinquante de quelqu'un est-ce
qu'il faut serrer les mains oui toutes
les heures est-ce que donc les parents
vont laisser tout à fait comme ça on
parfaite sérénité les enfants vont à
l'école même si le conseil scientifique
nous explique que n'y a aucun risque
il faut apporter des réponses à cette
angoisse permanente qui ont des parents
notamment qui n'ont pas envie de voir
leur progéniture dans un dans une
contamination potentielle et donc j'ai
fait quelques propositions au ministre
monsieur blanc caire pour justement
rassurer ses parents mettre en place un
dispositif qu'ils fassent en sorte que
les personnels éducatifs soient équipés
outils avec mascouche à masquer leur
stratégie pareil pour les personnels des
lycées qui dépend directement de la
région et qui permette l'ouverture des
lycées donc tout ça ça va se mettre en
place petit à petit avec un seul
objectif il faut qu'on apporte des
solutions aux multiples questions qui se
posent et qu'elles se passent toujours
avec beaucoup de bon sens de
différenciation et de déconcentration
exemple est simple dans les lycées nice
est générale à marseille c'est pas la
même chose que les lycées techniques à
manosque
si le lycée professionnel dans les
hautes-alpes absolument rien à voir avec
le lycée polyvalent à toulouse vous avez
des lycées de 800 places une règle 12
cents et donc tout ceci se prête face
aux différents sans avantage plus commun
dans la région provence alpes côte
d'azur c'est que cette année on avait
aidé investit très lourdement et très
fortement où tous les lisseurs des packs
des tablettes numériques
au moins ils ont pu avoir une continuité
éducative pendant sept heures de confier
devant une petite question sur les
masques renaud muselier c'est vous même
qui avez fait témoignage de la guerre
des masques il ya quelques semaines sur
ce plateau jérôme c'est le mans alençon
millions de masques importés chaque
semaine et qu'on sera en situation un
d'ici le 11 mai de répondre à la demande
vous y croyez ok je beaucoup de
commandes qui sont programmés et je vois
arriver vous donc coûté aide toi le ciel
t'aidera
dans la région provence alpes côte
d'azur après tout les difficultés qu'ont
rencontré les autres présidents de
région dans leurs commandes
nous nous avons mis un pont aérien avec
des commandes qui sont fixes les max des
masques qui ont les devants européenne
valider par le gouvernement chinois pour
quoi évidemment l'exportation qui passe
au centre qu'on a les bons de douane
pour les faits rapportés avec ses 20
filiales de cma-cgm qui le numéro de lot
juste des logiques d'un logistique au
mot et qui nous permet de faire un
plongeon de 5 millions de masques par
semaine dans la région provence alpes
côte d'azur en velin au moins cela ils
arriveront pour les autres on verra plus
tard
une réaction fait être globales sont ces
annonces emmanuel macron votre collègue
des républicains bruno retailleau chef
de file un des sénateurs les
républicains nous disait sur cette
prestation les annonces sur le
déconfinement sont totalement
incompréhensible on se demande pourquoi
le président de la république
s'affranchit de l'arrêt qu'il a lui même
fixé en dévoilant de manière précipitée
et brouillonne une partie du plan dont
il a confié la préparation et la
présentation à son premier ministre vous
seriez aussi sévère envers emmanuel
macron écouté il est resté quatre heures
avec les maires pour les écouter comme
tous ceux qui s'expriment et les grands
les petits les métropoles
au bout de quatre heures peut-être que
le président a voulu leur faire une
petite confidence
bon donc je suis un peu moins sévère en
tout cas ce que j'attends avec
impatience c'est un plan bien coordonné
après toutes ces discussions
la très grosse difficulté du débat c'est
que s'il arrivait qu'un plan to book lui
et on va lui expliquer qu'il a conservée
personnes et s'il concerne on va le dire
mais vous êtes le brouillon donc écouter
nous nous avons fait nos propositions
les régions de france nous sommes 18
région métropolitaine et outre-mer et
nous parlons de l'année le bois avec une
des propositions très claires et
concrètes
en espérant qu'elle soit parfaitement
intégré dans ce qui sera présenté la
semaine prochaine
boncourt renaud muselier président a
l'air de la région sud provence alpe
côte d'azur et présidents de régions de
france merci à vous et la france qui
déplore près de 22000 décès dus aux
coronavirus selon un nouveau bilan donné
par la direction générale de la santé
est la hausse de ces dernières 24 heures
est de 516 morts en léger retrait par
rapport à la veille
on le 15e jour consécutif le nombre de
personnes en réanimation a baissé de son
65 impatients et en attendant l'après 11
mai la pandémie et le confinement mettre
un coup d'arrêt à de nombreuses pme
55% des dirigeants de pme craignent à la
faillite à cause de la crise c'est ce
que nous révèle une enquête réalisée par
la confédération des petites et moyennes
entreprises manque de trésorerie retards
de paiement difficultés à honorer les
factures c'est un cercle vicieux dans
lesquelles sont plongés les
entrepreneurs d'un que certains
bénéficient d'un fonds de solidarité mis
en place par l'état et les régions et
pour en parler nous sommes avec denis
jacquet entrepreneurs président de
l'association parrainé la croissance
bonsoir denis jacquet merci d'être avec
nous en direct
38e jour donc de confinement les
frontières sont fermées l'économie est à
l'arrêt les entrepreneurs souffre il
semble que ce soit votre cas vous vous
travaillez entre miami et paris mais
vous êtes bloqués à paris vous dites
vous la tension le déconfinement ne va
pas assez vite pour quelle raison je
pense qu'en fait aujourd'hui ce qu'on
paye principalement mais c'est la
non-préparation nos économies
occidentales main si on regarde bien ce
qui se passe
vous prenez la corée vous prenez le fait
nam vous prenez hong kong qui est quand
même la plus grosse densité au monde
huit mille personnes au kilomètre carré
moins de quarante morts donc en réalité
à force de braquer les caméras tous les
soirs sur ce ce ce chapelet qui est
juste presque indécent du nombre de
morts quotidiens je ne veux même pas à
comprendre comment laisse passer à la
télé aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
la france meurt du coup tout le monde
est inquiet pense que retourner au
travail est dangereux parce qu'on est
tombé malade la réalité c'est que pour
l'instant nous avons trente personnes
hospitalisées mais trente personnes
mortes surtout pour 100000 habitants
convient appel
de dépasser les chiffres de la grippe de
2018 et que pour préserver je le
comprends c'est un choix politique
difficile mais à un moment donné ce
qu'on demande à un président de la
république c'est d'assurer le futur mme
de la plus grande partie de la
population dans quand vous avez 30
personnes pour cent mille qui meurt
quand vous avez deux perles dans la
majorité des départements français -
deux personnes dans des lits d'hôpitaux
aujourd'hui à moins de deux personnes
pour cent mille dans les hôpitaux égaux
tous concentre sur le grand test et sur
paris et que vous cantonniers pour
autant il nous confie nier 68 millions
d'individus
on risque mais c'est plus un risque
maintenant on le sait c'est une
récession qui est officiellement
déclarée qui va se traduire par des
morts par des dépressions par des
emplois qui ne sont recréeront jamais et
démocratiquement pas une seule certitude
c'est qu'aucun candidat démocrate ne
pourra l'emporter dans des tonneaux
démocratie dans les années qui viennent
je crois que tout le monde a oublié la
leçon de l'histoire c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'il ya eu des grandes récessions
dans les années qui ont suivi ce sont
toujours des populistes qui sont arrivés
au pouvoir donc je pense comprendre ou
un mort est toujours un mort je peux en
train de dire que ce n'est pas important
mais cette situation d'un virus qui ne
tue pas il tue uniquement parce que nous
ne sommes préparés parce que nous
n'avons pas de masque nous n'avons pas
de respirateur nous personnels
hospitaliers sont débordés mais quand la
crise a été bien préparé la lie le
prouve
vous n'avez qu'alimente allemand et
l'allemagne plus près de nous le prouve
avec très peu de morts mais 25 mille
lits d'hôpitaux des respirateurs un
personnel qui était prêt qui d'ailleurs
accueillez nôtre donc quand on parle
avec tous les végétaux leurs débats avec
un épidémiologiste qui disait
effectivement si vous me demandez à moi
médecins de prendre une décision bien
sûr je vais confiné longtemps parce que
mon rôle c'est de sauver les gens
si j'ouvre mezzo nommé the year de
médecins et que je pense aux dégâts
qu'on est en train de poser dans la
société je crois que c'était la première
fois que j'entendais un médecin aussi
humble et aussi ouvert il a
effectivement peut-être qu'on doit se
poser la question de savoir si pour
sauver quelques milliers de personnes
supplémentaires on doit plonger dans
l'indigence des millions mais c'est ans
que ce compte est en train de faire et
donc ne je n'arrive pas à comprendre
cette politique généralisée du
confinement
je n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'on dès
qu'on finisse à plus vite donnez-moi
denis jacquet mais c'est pourtant la
politique
qui est pratiqué partout dans le monde y
compris en asie où il ya eu quand même
plusieurs milliers de morts on ne
connaît pas d'ailleurs peut-être les
chiffres exacts en chine quand je
n'étais soirée jeudi mais on allemagne
ait des morts également plusieurs
centaines de 5000 morts plusieurs
milliers de morts tout le monde joue le
confinement alors qu'on n'ait pas été
préparés c'est une chose vous reprochez
peut-être au gouvernement d'en faire
trop détriment de l'économie d'en faire
trop en faveur peut-être de la santé de
nos concitoyens sans doute les plus
fragiles effectivement oui mais je pense
que pourquoi les économies
principalement aujourd'hui le seul qui
est sûrement menti sur ces chiffres
c'est la chine
néanmoins vous remarquerez que même si
ces 80 milles sur un 10 ans et demi de
personnes
franchement nous sommes comme le disait
malheureusement et raul tu sais même pas
l'épaisseur du trait de plume ça ne
changera rien à la démographie chinoise
je rappelle que 40000 même 80 milles
c'est énorme
il faut savoir qu aux etats unis la
grippe en 2018 a fait 76 victimes
donc aujourd'hui on est très très loin
de ce conte donc et surtout les autres
pays d'avis aujourd'hui cette épidémie
n'a pas tué elle s'est propagé
rapidement mais beaucoup moins
rapidement avec moins de morts pourquoi
baba d'abord parce que c'est un virus
qui est pas extrêmement dangereux il est
extrêmement dangereux pour les gens qui
ont des comorbidités mais qui sont
principalement des hommes et qui sont
plus de 75 ou 80 ans mais aujourd'hui on
empêche de travailler non pas cela mais
tous les autres et en asie on a mis très
vite les plus âgés à l'écart pour qu'il
soit protégé que surtout il n'y ait pas
d'effets les effets minimum sur ces gens
là et les autres pouvaient travailler
parce que pourquoi aujourd'hui notamment
une femme qui a 35 ans et qui travaille
à une chance sur un milliard d'êtres de
se retrouver en réanimation dans un
hôpital donc du coup tous les testeurs 6
ans et qu'est ce qu'une jeunesse choses
mais aujourd'hui il est clairement il
est il est très clair qu'aujourd'hui en
tout cas le chiffre que tout le monde a
donné dans tous les pays occidentaux
c'est que plus de 80% des gens qui
meurent meurent parce qu'on n'a pas le
temps de les traiter parce qu'ils ont
des comorbidités parce que ce sont des
hommes de plus de 75 ou 80 ans donc on
interdise aux gens de venir travailler
10 maintenant mais je veux pas je vais
être malade
les malades de coire 80 2 % des gens
ne se sont même pas aperçus qu'ils
avaient le virus donc ce que je dis
simplement c'est que on ne mesure pas le
seul dans le monde aujourd'hui c'est
d'ailleurs étonnant parce qu'on l'accuse
toujours d'être harper un idiot qui est
trump il a dit mr on ne peut pas confier
la décision uniquement à des médecins il
faut aussi la confier à des
intellectuels à des entrepreneurs à des
économistes parce que eux au moins
savent mesurer que sinon on doit faire
un choix un moment donné qui est très
dur à faire mais si on doit avoir
quelques centaines de malades en plus
quelques milliers de morts en plus mais
qu on sauve des centaines de millions de
personnes
malheureusement il faut faire le choix
de la majorité de ceux qui vivent et
donc aujourd'hui puisqu'il faut
comprendre aussi c'est que ceux qui vont
mourir des toutes petites et moyennes
entreprises
nous nous ce sont des entreprises et des
jobs que nous ne retrouverons jamais
mais ça qu'il est terrible dans cette
crise merci beaucoup
denis jacquet entre le président de
l'association parrainé la croissance
merci d'avoir été en direct sur rt
français alors que les modalités un de
déconfinement progressive sont peu un
peu livrée par le gouvernement il sera
présenté aux alentours de mardi cette
stratégie était la bonne pour qui ou
pourquoi la résolution de la crise
sanitaire est elle compatible avec la
santé économique du pays c'est justement
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
très pour en débattre
nous sommes en direct avec philippe
muray re économistes bonsoir philippe
muray amer sont avec nous à ses côtés
bertron le grand médecin généraliste à
tourcoing bonsoir docteur le grand merci
à vous d'être là également direct à
distance avec nous je sais pas si vous
avez entendu mon invité précédent cet
entrepreneur denis jacquet qui avait
certainement un discours qu'on entend
peuvent probablement je dirais
politiquement incorrect ça vous a fait
bondir vous le médecin bertrand legrand
alors ça m'a fait bondir je n'oublie pas
quand même que l'épidémie est venu de
chine et que les personnes qui l'ont
ramené en france ont été essentiellement
des personnes qui venaient de chine
probablement des cadres dirigeants et
qui ont propagé la maladie
au fur et à mesure de leurs contacts et
que nous avons il devait que 200
personnes
à peine revenu chila à ce moment là
c'est un virus qui circule est un vieux
circulent en silence c'est à dire qu'il
n'y a pas au moins 50% d'un fantomatique
et quant aux chiffres de décès qui ont
intéressé je renverrai à l'étude du jama
qui est paru hier le 22 qui montrent que
76,4 % des personnes de 18 à 65 ans qui
ont sont sous respirateur sont morts à
new york et 97
j'ai vu le 2 % des cultes 65 ans sont
morts donc je pense que ce discours est
totalement irresponsable
les gens qui nous mettons sous
respirateur actuellement ont des chances
de survie extrêmement minces et nous
avons la chance d'avoir suffisamment de
respirateurs pour aplanir la cour
or c'est ce que nous faisons en france
actuellement et c'est pour ça que vous
voyez pas l'île des morts
mais bon moral même statistique et cette
étude est la plus grande étude qui fait
publier au niveau mondial elle touche
5000 patients oui
pardonnez-moi filmera vous êtes
économiste
on comprend effectivement l'inquiétude
et le désarroi de l'entrepreneur denis
jacquet il est compliqué effectivement
de mettre ce curseur entre crises
sanitaires sauver des vies qui paraît
être une priorité dans nos sociétés et
finalement la crise économique qui
laissera beaucoup de personnes beaucoup
d'entreprises sur le carreau quel est
votre avis sur cette question
mon avis que c'est que ce n'était pas si
compliqué mais fallait pas faire des
demi mesures sanitaires et des demi
mesures économiques
il fallait d'abord gérer la crise
sanitaire alors comme on n'a pas fermé
les frontières comme on n'a pas de
masques etc
il fallait faire un confinement strict
plus stricte pour en quatre semaines
gérer la crise sanitaire et gérait
ensuite la crise économique en fait il
était tout à fait possible et je pense
que le gouvernement macron devrait
écouter les entrepreneurs il faut que
toutes les charges des entreprises les
impôts ne soit pas reporté mais annulée
sur les deux mois de confinement au pur
avec philippe murray revient sur les
charges sociales et salariales
alors oui on vous a un petit peu perdues
fini perverse pour ça je me suis permis
de vous êtes sacrées il est excusé moi
oui on vous a coupé tout simplement vous
à continuer votre raisonnement ça a
coupé
adacore excusez moi donc en fait il
fallait annuler tout cela annulé tous
les impôts bien payer tous les salaires
entièrement de toutes les entreprises
arrêtent et si les entreprises reçoivent
à moitié arrêté il fallait payer en fait
annuler la moitié des impôts et la
moitié des salaires pour qu'elle ne se
détruisent pas parce que l'entrepreneur
cet entrepreneur a raison sur un point
si on ne fait pas tout pour qu'elle ne
se détruisent pas une partie du tissu
économique français sera définitivement
perdue avec des résultats extrêmement
grave au niveau économique donc il faut
tout faire pour éviter cela dr legrand
sur le point de finalement ce que dit un
petit peu donald trump a confié paca des
médecins justement la gestion de cette
épidémie mais aussi à des entrepreneurs
des économies ça vous paraît saugrenue
comme idée c'est une excellente idée
nous on a besoin des entrepreneurs on a
besoin d'avoir le monde de l'entreprise
type ut et qu'ils se mettent à produire
des masques qui ces mecs là la future
dessoude des sur blues ainsi que tout le
matériel qui nous avons besoin ce qu'on
remarque c'est effectivement je suis
assez d'accord avec ce que nous disons
c'est l'impréparation qui est la
sanction
le confinement qui dure n'est que la
résultante de l'absence d'anticipation
de la part du gouvernement
je vous rappelle que l'événement avait
parfaitement anticipé des choses il
avait détestant désert il avait des
masters les arcs
il avait des usines en train de tourner
est en train de faire des marchés nous
on n'a pas de masque on est des sacs
poubelles pour se protéger
c'est une honte absolue et le soutien
qu'on la veut bien le dire c'est pas
l'état qui nous inquiète c'est les
entreprises de btp qui se délestent de
leurs matériels pour protéger les
médecins parce que même dans des tp on
as tu appris qu'un médecin malade était
un médecin contagieux et le gouvernement
est le seul à ne pas comprendre que
cette maladie tue maladies nosocomiales
que c'est les médecins les soignants qui
sont condamnés à plus de 30 à 40% et qui
portons maladie
donc effectivement le conflit non c'est
très intelligent sauf que si j'avais les
premiers 4 5 qui soignent les malades
sont comptables et et on y arrive à
gérer l'environnement effectivement
il faut mettre d'accord aujourd'hui
quelles solutions à partir du moment
voilà où les masques tarde à venir alors
là on nous en promet effectivement des
millions et qu'on sera prêt a priori sur
pour le 6 mai idem pour les tests quel
serait pour vous la solution philippe
murray reste que c'est déjà trop tard
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya un problème
c'est qu'on manque de masse qu'il
faudrait presque 50 millions de masques
par jour
si on veut que tout le monde puisse
avoir des masques un milliard cinq par
mois on n'y arrivera pas moi j'appelle
un appel je lance un appel aux médecins
pour dire faites en sorte qu'on puisse
recycler ses marcy demandé au
gouvernement de faire des études pour
qu'on puisse recycler nos masques parce
que sinon on en aura jamais assez et ça
posera un problème de transmission quand
tout le monde se remettra à travailler
l'autre chose moi je me pose la question
on à 65 mille malades officielle
aujourd'hui c'est le gouvernement dit
qu'on en a plutôt dit foie malade ça
fait beaucoup de virus qui circulent moi
j'ai vraiment un doute pour dire on peut
d confié dans deux semaines et demie
malheureusement ça me paraît très
compliqué bertrand legrand ça vous
paraît également très compliqué ça veut
dire que cette deuxième vague on ne va
pas y couper
selon vous avec ce déconfinement
programmée au ciné oui alors recycler
les masques c'est possible on le fait on
aime tant elles étaient contraints et si
on élit des départs en masse tout laisse
à le répéter on n'aurait pas autant de
morts sans les soigner
c'est la première chose dont vous pouvez
mettre notre masque de côté les faire
patienter pendant cinq six jours et il
est très peu compté mais en ce moment là
où passer dans ce message il ya plein de
solutions d énormes et qui sont
fonctionnaires csf un choc des choses le
confinement vie on a un stock de
personnes asymptomatiques
le fait de choisir aujourd'hui de texter
il est symptomatique dans libéré et
quatre sur dix qu'ils sont pourtant
malade
un texte qui a une sensibilité qui
eiffel va retenir à propager la maladie
à une vitesse très rapide donc
effectivement je vous confiant dès qu'on
va les confiner dès qu on avait appliqué
la politique de tests sur des personnes
symptomatique
on va juste libéré des gens contagieux
et qui m'ont protégé la reine est pas en
salle d'armes automatiques ne se rend
même pas contrôler donc c'est
complètement stupide mais forcément on
est une stupidité près on passe de
stupide en mesure stupide la france est
championne merci beaucoup à tous les
deux philippe muray ray bertrand legrand
d'avoir été avec nous pour ce face à
face rester avec nous donc quelques
instants l'europe qui tente bon gré mal
gré de s'accorder sur un plan de relance
économique post crise puis nous
parlerons de la pandémie qui risque
d'aggraver la situation des populations
au bord de la famine déjà en forte
augmentation en 2019 et qui pourrait
doubler en 2020
[Musique]
est ce qu'on sait combien d'enfants sont
victimes de ces violences et qui sont
concernés par ces drames qui se déroule
dans le huis clos familial
or dans la période actuelle il est
difficile de dire précisément combien
d'enfants sont concernés car en fait on
a très peu de visibilité
nous savons simplement que il y à des
situations effectivement qui s'aggrave
dans les familles il ya toutes les
classes sociales qui sont concernés par
la maltraitance il faut qu'on le dise
ils redisent là le problème c'est que
dans le cas du confinement il n'y a plus
cet entourage et tout se fait à distance
ce qui fait qu'il est très difficile de
repérer par téléphone par visiophone ces
situations et notre inquiétude un porte
plutôt sur ce que vous pouvez non pas la
partie immergée de l'iceberg en fait
parce que les très difficile pour les
enfants malgré tout d'appeler le même et
dans ce cas là on n'entend rien ça se
fait totalement dans le silence
[Musique]
certains disent que nous sommes pas une
chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même si
on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici seul interdit d'interdire
20h30 merci de nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france deuxième partie d'émission
largement consacrée vous le savez à la
crise du coronavirus dans l'aude
emmanuel macron a pris la parole tout à
l'heure durant quelques minutes alors qu
avait lieu aujourd'hui en
visioconférence le sommet européen entre
états membres
le chef de l'état a fait le point sur la
coordination entre les pays de l'ue eux
en cette période de pandémie et surtout
sur le devoir de solidarité et la
volonté d'apporter une réponse forte et
donc compte tenu d'une part de devoir
d'unité de solidité de l'union
européenne et de la zone euro et d'autre
part de la magnitude de ce choc
il nous faut une réponse solidaire
organisé est forte
c'est cela ce que nous avons commencé à
discuter ce sur quoi nous avons demandé
à la commission de travailler à la fois
pour en définir les montants tels qu'on
les envisage aujourd'hui les secteurs
prioritaires et les mécanismes et pour
en parler nous sommes en direct depuis
liverpool avec francesco rizzuto
professeur de droit européen
l'université de hadj il c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir francesco risotto merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france vous
venez de l'entendre un emmanuel macron
qui appelle à la solidarité européenne
et au final qui chargeant les 27
les 27 ans qui charge la commission de
présenter un fonds de relance d'ici le 6
mai vous y croyez ce fonds de relance au
niveau européen pour sauver justement
l'europe de cette terrible crise qui se
profile à clamer sa chance que nous
avons de ses conseillers que des états
eux mêmes
la véritable question est ce que cela
passera par mes équipiers europe nous
allons nous mettre en place d'autres
mécanismes que l'issue de cette
fermeture
c'était même temps pas de consensus sur
les transferts budgétaires vers certains
pays a dit emmanuel macron est-ce qu'il
faut repenser tout le système
selon vous je sais je te suivre les
réactions par exemple en italie italie
que la situation avance
cela ne fait aucun doute ce qu'on va
trouver des consensus sur le principe
d'un fonds fait de relance il ya
également prince en sus sur le passage
devant la commission
d'ailleurs cela se rajoute 540 milliards
qui ont déjà été décidées aujourd'hui
faudrait laisser la place à davantage
d'autonomie d'autonomie pour les pays
davantage de souveraineté vous pensez
que ça serait une meilleure
solution à tout est à [ __ ] les détails
de l'annoncé malheureuse mans l'idée que
un virus comme le cordage et russes
respecterait les frontières et que nous
pourrions préserver en avoir une
frontière
tu es passé fallacieuse je pense que ce
qui va changer suite à sa patrie je
salutaire c'est que l'on va s'en rendre
compte au niveau des états européens
individuellement ou collectivement il
faudra se concentrer bien plus de temps
sur des choses que l'on a laissé à la
merci des marchés ou des pays tiers
il y aura donc un attention renforcée
sur ce que ma cour a appelé la
souveraineté européenne en plus de la
souveraineté nationale
l'europe qui s'est construit en plein
marasme
est-ce que c'est précisément dans ce
genre de crise qu'elle doit selon vous
montrer sa cohésion ou au contraire il
ya un risque de fracture à l'issue de
cette pandémie qui va être extrêmement
violente on a déjà les premiers chiffres
1 pour l'europe mais pas seulement
j'aime tout acabit le véritable problème
à plus tard
parce que lorsque les négociations les
gens vont commencer à repenser à ce que
leur apporter les autres pays
je pense que beaucoup des personnes en
europe ceux du sud seront tous très
mécontentes de la façon dont les pays du
nord de l'europe qu'elle la hollande
notamment les pays bas se sont comportés
les sud ne demandez pas au nord de
rembourser toutes ses dettes le sud
demandent quelque chose de complètement
différent
je ne suis pas en train de dire que
l'union européenne va se disloquer
mais à moins que les choses avancent
rapidement au cours des mois à venir
alors l'union européenne il se portera
pas très bien en cours des prochaines
années
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation
parce que même un pays qu'on sait assez
dogmatiques 1 l'allemagne se dit prête à
payer plus même si par exemple sur le
sujet des corps d'un bon on est bien ça
reste une ligne rouge pour angela merkel
que faudrait faudrait-il adopté comme
attitude pour ces pays justement je
pense qu'il serait mieux de passer par
le budget européen que les biens contre
les plus plus qu on obtient et des
mèches transferts c'est par là que je
suis sur mer et le budget que l'on
serait obligé va devoir augmenter de
toute façon quand les participations
avec le brésil et la tête de la
population des tourniquets
c'est une sorte une forme de solidarité
qui existe au sein des traités en pas
donc besoin d'inventer de nouveaux
instruments de toutes pièces on n'a pas
besoin de se lancer dans des manigances
politiques au niveau des états pour moi
ce serait la meilleure solution pour
avancer
et bien sûr il faudrait également l'aide
de la bce de la banque d'investissement
et etc
c'est la direction que nous prenons mais
cela ne peut pas durer toujours
aujourd'hui on le voit le commande
chaque jour sur nos antennes chaque pays
a une manière différente de gérer la
crise avec plus ou moins de succès on
citera personne est ce qu'il est normal
qu'à la fin tout le monde contribue de
manière égale selon vous en europe c'est
que je veux comme lui tout seul très
interconnecté donc effectivement nous
allons tous devoir contribuer les
personnes qui ont plus de ressources et
qu'ils ont plus bénéficié du marché
intérieur devrait à mon sens montrer ce
que angela merkel a qualifié de plus
grande solidarité
un grand succès au cours des deux ou
trois dernières semaines c'est que la
naïve même si la rhétorique n'a pas
changé mon petit qu'il n'y aura pas de
corona bond l'allemagne accepte ce
qu'elle devra endosser plus de
responsabilités car elle a plus de
ressources tout simplement et leur
bien-être dépendu de la prospérité des
pays plus plus faible si cela fait sens
merci beaucoup francesco rizzuto
professeur de droit européen université
de jill merci à vous et lutter contre le
coronavirus est évidemment trouver un
vaccin tout le monde l'espère les
recherches en europe s'intensifie avec
l'allemagne et le royaume uni qui lance
aujourd'hui des essais cliniques
justement autrement je le bilan
s'alourdit avec 616 morts
supplémentaires lors des dernières 24
heures au total plus de 18000 700 décès
mais financial times affirme que la
pandémie aurait déjà causé jusqu'à 41
mille morts dans le même temps londres
affirme vouloir poursuivre les mesures
de distanciation sociales jusqu'à la fin
de l'année
tant que nous n'aurons pas de vaccin et
la probabilité d'un autre tenir dans
l'année qui suit reste extrêmement
faible
je pense que nous devons être réalistes
nous allons devoir compter sur d'autres
mesures sociales qui bien sûr sont très
déstabilisante comme tout le monde
découvre actuellement
mais d'ici là c'est ce que nous devrons
faire et c'est la meilleure façon de
maximiser nos chances de combattre le
virus mais cela va prendre beaucoup de
temps et je pense que nous devons en
être conscients troisième légère hausse
à défiler des décès en espagne troisième
pays le plus endeuillé au monde le pic
est passé alors que le pays compte plus
de 22 mille victimes les hôpitaux ne
sont plus saturés fort heureusement mais
le déconfinement ne devrait pas
intervenir avant la mi mai selon le chef
du gouvernement espagnol pedro sanchez
pour en parler nous sommes avec roanne
rosé dorado journalistes espagnols
bonsoir honneur aux et dorado merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors
on l'a commenté les choses s'améliorent
plus de saturation il n'empêche ya
toujours une augmentation des décès
alors qu'on se profile vers le
déconfinement quel est l'état d'esprit
des espagnols on imagine qu'ils doivent
être très éprouvés après des semaines de
confinement assez stricte et un nom de
victimes extrêmement important
effectivement c'est le cas l'espagne en
sont éprouvés parce que vous savez que
le confinement espagnol et le plus dur
de tous les pays européens exemple ce
n'est qu'à partir dès dimanche que les
enfants espagnols vont pouvoir sortir au
moins une heure dans la rue et pas plus
loin d'un kilomètre comme en france ça
fait cinq semaines
quel est son fond espagnols sont
confinés son savoir le droit de sortir
ni une seule fois dans la rue donc mais
même avec cette chiffre-là les espagnols
dans ce sondage
apparu il y a quelques jours s'est dit
c'est que 73 % étaient pour le
prolongement du confinement est pourquoi
tout simplement parce que vous l'avez
dit aujourd'hui ses vingt-deux mille
morts ou encore en espagne aujourd'hui
c'est plus de 2000 personnes contaminées
aujourd'hui c'est encore plus de 4600
contamination par jour l'os espagnol
souhaite pouvoir finir avec le
confinement mais en même temps ils
voient que les chiffres font font froid
dans le dos donc d'un côté oui il
faudrait commencer à sortir parce que
les pays est fortement touché l'économie
espagnole est fortement touchée
d'ailleurs on commence à se poser la
question comment est-ce qu'on va s'en
sortir si on n'a pas l'air des autres
pays européens
mais pour l'instant les espagnols et
c'est tout simplement des survivre si
vous permettez cette expression et d
essayer d'enrayer cette pandémie que qu
on vous l'avait dit à fait plus des 22
mille morts déjà en espagne à la juan
jose haedo radio vous nous parler du
bilan qui est effectivement très
important il n'empêche que la presse se
fait écho du fait que l'essentiel des
décès ne figurerait pas dans les
statistiques officielles a lancé le cas
aussi dans d'autres pays et le royaume
uni
c'est la même chose la france pareil
j'ai toujours cette suspicion entre le
bilan officiel est le vrai bilan pour
comprendre d'ailleurs ce qui a pu se
passer en espagne la justice a ouvert
semble-t-il 86 enquête préliminaire
expliquez nous effectivement il ya eu de
son enquête préliminaire ouverte par la
justice notamment par rapport aux à
l'équivalent des ehpad en france pour
comprendre comment il est possible qu'il
y ait eu au tandem des ddc et qu'on ait
pas su qu'on ne laissait pas annoncé
quand il compte il le fallait vous savez
que par exemple les morts dans les ehpad
assez surtout l'armé quand elle a été
déployée qui les as tu découvert pour la
pour la pour la plupart il y a quelques
semaines il ya près d'un deuxième ligne
des régions espagnoles a dû reconnaître
qu'il y avait certainement plus de 3000
morts en plus de ce qui était annoncé et
la réalité est qu'aujourd'hui le
gouvernement espagnol est fortement
contesté et les espagnols considèrent
que la crise est assez mal géré les
chiffres montrent que vingt-deux mille
morts ce n'est pas avoir bien géré et
c'est de cette crise
vous savez et les espagnols aussi ses
poses la question sur le pourcentage par
exemple des personnels sanitaires qui
est contaminée l'espagne à ce triste
record seul pays d'europe où il ya le
plus d personnel sanitaire médecins
infirmiers aides soignants contaminés
par les coronavirus plus des 25000
personnes le sont aujourd'hui
et effectivement la justice espagnole
donc a été cécile par rapport au décès
dont les étapes mais aussi par rapport
aux associations des médecins par
exemple qui ont déposé plainte plainte
par contre le gouvernement espagnol est
contre le président espagnol par
négligence juste un chiffre il faut
savoir que le gouvernement espagnol a
acheté plusieurs millions des masques
mais récemment il a dû rendre 700 mille
masques qui avaient été distribués au
personnel soignant parce que ces masques
n'était pas bonne et d'été et des
masques qui ne correspondaient pas aux
standards et qui ont permis par exemple
quand je vous disais la contamination de
personnel soignant
donc aujourd'hui le gouvernement est
contestée parce qu'il n'a pas su gérer
combler nabeul convenablement
cette crise et malté n'ont certainement
dans quelques semaines dans quelques
mois plus tôt la justice aura à se
prononcer d'un côté sur le nombre de
morts et qui est revue à laver
systématiquement par les gouvernements
compensée par les gouvernements
autonomes que les décès déclarés dans
les mairies sont des plus en plus
importante les chiffres ne cadre pas
calé dans ce contexte le moral au sein
de la population à ce que ceux des
confinement qui se profile un le 9 mai
d'ailleurs et des industries qui ont
déjà ouvertes en espagne est ce que
c'est une perspective quand même dû qui
met du baume au coeur même si vous
l'avez dit certains espagnols demandent
à rester à 1 confiné effectivement la
date est pour l'instant est celle du 9
mai puisque l'état d'urgence a été donc
que prolonger jusqu'à cette date du 9
mai par la suite de toute façon le
gouvernement et son président a déjà
annoncé que le confinement on va se
faire comme en france on voit à peu près
dé façon progressive
mais par contre il n'a pas encore dit
quelle comment ça va se faire
directement on se pose la question du
nombre de masques soufis sont pour que
les gens puissent sortir dans la rue on
se pose la question des tests
est ce qu'on aura cédé test pour pouvoir
tester et les espagnols qui vont sortir
on sait par contre effectivement déjà qu
elle accompagna touristique d'été est
complètement ratée d'ailleurs le
gouvernement va maintenir au moins
jusqu'à la mi-juin pour l'instant les
frontières espagnoles fermé mais il est
très probable effectivement qu'elle soit
beaucoup plus retarder l'ouverture des
ces et frontière espagnole donc il y a
l'ovi de pouvoir commencer à sortir mais
en même temps les espagnols ont aussi la
peur au ventre
dd se dire qu'est ce chiffre des
vingt-deux mille morts pourrait croître
énormément
si le contenu des compliments n'était
pas fait correctement et donc devant
c'était équation il préférerait quand je
vous disais dans un récent sondage
continuer un peu plus confiné mais
s'assurer que le de confinement
n'apportera pas plus de morts merci
beaucoup ron rosé dorado journalistes
espagnols d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france pour nous parler
de la situation donc en espagne et
derrière la crise sanitaire en afrique
une crise alimentaire qui se profile le
nombre de personnes infectées pourraient
doubler selon le programme alimentaire
mondial si des mesures ne sont pas
prises rapidement
les précisions de clément hospital des
scènes de couilles lors de la
distribution des aides alimentaires en
plein coeur de la capitale kényane des
habitants d'un bidonville de nairobi
bousculer piétinées alors qu'une crise
probablement plus graves que le
coronavirus est en train de gagner le
continent africain
c'est de la pénurie alimentaire comme
vous pouvez le voir des gens sont battus
certains ont amené leurs enfants et sont
blessés
ce n'est pas juste nous ne recevons pas
de nourriture à kibera ceci n'est qu'un
moyen de contacter directement le virus
ne faisons rien pour nous protéger
contre le virus
mourir de faim ou contracter la maladie
un vrai dilemme auquel fait face
actuellement l'afrique
l'onu redoute que la pandémie de
coronavirus ne soit un facteur aggravant
de la pénurie alimentaire
la fermeture des marchés et la récession
économique devrait entraîner une perte
de revenus importante pour les
travailleurs pauvres
selon le directeur du programme
alimentaire mondial des nations unies
le pea m 135 millions de personnes
supplémentaires sont confrontés à
différents niveaux de crise de la faim
ou pire cela signifie que 135 millions
de personnes sur terre sont au bord de
la famine
mais maintenant l'analyse du programme
alimentaire mondial montre également
qu'en raison du coronavirus 130 millions
d'autres personnes pourraient être
poussés au bord de la famine d'ici la
fin de 2020
cela représente un total de 265 millions
de personnes pour venir en aide aux plus
démunis
le programme alimentaire mondial des
nations unies tentent de fournir une
aide médicale et humanitaire au pays
durement touché par la crise les
organismes
manille terre redoutent que l'insécurité
alimentaire s'aggrave dans plusieurs
pays et territoires également bouleversé
par des conflits et selon typhaine à
walton porte parole du pam en france
mais il ne faut pas rajouter de la crise
à la crise
on a fait un appel de 350 millions de
dollars pour pouvoir renforcer notre
chaîne logistique mettre en place de
nouveaux hubs au pouvoir permettre la
distribution rapide et le
prépositionnement aussi de stock et
aussi pour servir l'ensemble de la
communauté humanitaire donc les oeufs
les ong les autres agences des nations
unies pour qu'on puisse déplacer plus
facilement les personnels humanitaires
personnels de santé et matériels aussi
de santé s'ils ont malheureusement on
n'a pas les moyens de poursuivre nos
opérations et de poursuivre nos
opérations logistiques également on
risque d'avoir trois cent mille
personnes par jour et pourrait m'ouvrir
de la faim dans les trois prochains mois
il faut pas qu'on en rajoute encore plus
du risque pour des personnes qui doivent
se rassembler sur des points de
distribution mais il ya souvent beaucoup
de monde donc ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
a mis en place dès bien entendu des
règles de distanciation sociale des
stations de lavage de mains on a
multiplié les points de distribution
pour qu'ils aient moins de personnes et
la fréquence des distributions aussi en
dogues ont pour le peu plus de rations
plus de vivre personne pour qu'elle
n'ait pas à revenir immédiatement
cherché le mois suivant
du côté de la tunisie au confinement
général prendra fin le 3 mai et le pays
se prépare à vivre un ramadan idée dit l
heure du confinement on retrouve sur
place notre reporter bassam chebbi
bonsoir presse m
demain c'est donc le début du ramadan le
gouvernement tunisien pris des mesures
exceptionnelles pour l'occasion comment
vont s'organiser les tunisiens pour ce
mois de jeunes en pleine pandémie
effectivement c'est un mois assez
spécial que les tunisiens s'apprêtent à
vivre un mois du ramadan qui est connu
dans le monde entier dans le monde
musulman surtout comme un mois où les
familles se réunissent énormément où les
gens ont l'habitude de sortir et qui se
réuniront notamment à la mosquée après
la rupture du jeûne cette année ça va
être différent un cas de figure
complètement exceptionnel ce soit en
tunisie ou alors dans le reste du monde
le gouvernement a déjà pris ces
dispositions il a annoncé que le
couvre-feu passerait de 18 heures à 20
heures pour permettre aux tunisiens de
pouvoir et s'y retrouver et puis pouvoir
profiter de ce mois sans aucune pression
le confinement reste est temps qu'elle
vit toujours d'actualité le gouvernement
a annoncé qu'à partir du 3 mai il y
aurait un techniquement partiel par
région et par secteur d'activité et on a
pu observer depuis hier que les rues
étaient beaucoup plus bondées que
d'habitude que les marchés étaient plus
bondées que d'habitude et tunisiens sont
de plus en plus nombreux à vouloir se
proposait à faire des progrès
circulez accra des provisions pardon
pour ce mois du ramadan mais quelques
consignes sont respectées par normandeau
gouvernorat et de mairie notamment à
distance sociale des préventions le port
du masque aux leurres l'utilisation de
gels hydro alcooliques mais le
gouvernement craint quand même que la
population soit amené et puis tenté de
sortir un peu plus homogène avant que le
les noms de sécurité ne soit pas
respecté et plus gouvernement a
également annoncé qu'une aide financière
supplémentaire sera louée aux familles
les plus démunies pour pouvoir tenir
tout ce mois de ramadhan bon voilà une
situation exceptionnelle pour les
tunisiens pour les musulmans dans le
reste de la planète
donc il va les avoir il va falloir
s'adapter cette année pour ce ramadan et
qui bien sûr ne pas oublier qu'on est
encore en pleine pandémie du comité
disent n'être et surtout faire attention
merci ben hassen chébili en direct de
tunisie
les etats unis premier foyer mondial de
la pandémie avec plus de 47000 morts
dans plusieurs états les mobilisations
qui confinement se poursuivre
les manifestants demandent la
réouverture des commerces et industries
pour relancer l'économie demande
soutenue par donald trump le locataire
de la maison blanche qui a signé un
décret limitant temporairement
l'immigration sur le sol américain
une façon selon lui de donner de
meilleures chances aux millions
d'américains soudainement au chômage de
trouver un travail
tg nos grands travailleurs américains
je viens de signer un décret exécutif
suspendant temporairement l'immigration
aux états unis cela garantira que les
chômeurs américains le tour ils ont soit
prioritaire pour les emplois alors que
notre économie offrira il permettra
également de préserver nos ressources de
soins de santé pour les patients
américains
nous devons prendre soin de nos patients
nous devons prendre soin de nos grands
travailleurs américains est toujours aux
etats-unis le missouri porte plainte
contre la chine pour avoir caché des
informations cruciales au début de la
pandémie pékin de son côté pour
compenser le retrait américain annonce
vouloir offrir 30 millions de dollars
supplémentaires à l' oms emilie qoqa ch
une plainte qui vise directement le
gouvernement chinois
le parti communiste mais aussi d'autres
hauts responsables des institutions du
pays
selon eric schmidt pékin a dissimulé des
informations capitales y laisser le
corona virus se propage et avant de
prendre les mesures nécessaires durant
les premières semaines de l'épidémie les
autorités chinoises ont trompé le public
censurer des informations cruciales
arrêter des lanceurs d'alert nier la
transmission entre humains malgré des
preuves de plus en plus nombreuse
détruit des recherches médicales vitales
laissé des millions de personnes sont
exposées au virus et même garder en
stock des équipements de protection
provoquant un signe pandémie inutiles
que l'on aurait pu empêcher des
accusations démenties par la diplomatie
chinoise
son porte parole les qualifie de
malveillantes et abusive pour game show
ang
le gouvernement chinois a toujours
partagé ces informations cette
soi-disant accusation qui n'a aucune
baisse
actuel et juridique est absurde le
gouvernement chinois a toujours adopté
une attitude ouverte transparente et
responsable
il a informé en temps utile oms et les
pays et régions concernées y compris les
états unis en leur communiquant
plusieurs séries d'informations il a
répondu activement aux préoccupations de
toutes les parties et il a renforcé la
coopération avec la communauté
internationale
il ya quelques jours donald trump a lui
accusé la chine de cacher le véritable
bilan de l'épidémie
pékin a fermement démenti d'autres chefs
d'état et de gouvernement ont demandé
aux chinois plus de clarté le président
français emmanuel macron a fait part de
ses doutes sur la transparence
revendiquée par les autorités chinoises
en allemagne la chancelière fédérale
angela merkel a elle demandé à pékin de
faire la lumière sur l'origine de la
pandémie
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons des services de
renseignement qui redoublent de
vigilance dans un monde bouleversé par
la pandémie ou la trêve n'existe pas et
puis ce sera les dites aux échos de
jacques sapir alors que les prix du
pétrole se sont écoulés en début de
semaine comment en est on arrivé là
peut-on expliquer par la seule crise du
coronavirus secteur pétrolier peut-il
s'en relever
on donnera la réponse
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on a une idée d'augmentation
ou pas des féminicides aujourd'hui en
france l'écho et les violences existait
avant le confinement et pendant ce
compliment c'est vrai qu'il ya sept ce
cadre lecture les dos des féminicides a
plus que j'étais pas doublé mais bien
monté forcément on n'a pas encore tous
les chiffres officiels c'est très
difficile
groen et jamais des amiénois finalement
c'est le confinement dans le confinement
cela veut dire qu'il ya un huis clos au
sein des foyers
et forcément donc les femmes victimes de
violences de nombreux endroits à 3
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
nous allons évoquer ici des sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous mon
interprétation quelle que soit la
qualité expertise indéniable nos soldats
ils ne peuvent gagner la guerre pour la
raison que je vais maintenant est ce que
peuvent faire un peu plus de 5000
militaires français à l'efficacité
certes reconnu sur une zone aussi vaste
même renforcé par cinq mille soldats
promis par les pays vieux 500 c'est là
où les problèmes ont commencé
les déclarations récentes des politiques
des spécialistes des experts des
militaires montre bien que nous sommes
face à une incompréhension totale entre
les différents acteurs
si la france n'a pas la volonté
nécessaire pour assurer la réalisation
de ses objectifs et de les accompagner
parce qu'il ne s'agit pas d'imposer il
s'agit de convaincre et d'accompagner il
est à craindre que nous terminions
enlisé dans un conflit sans fin
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce que vous
viviez un peu dans la peur avec tino
quai des menaces oui d intimidation
comme brûler les locaux oui mais un
assassinat vraiment jeune ans je pense
que j'y croyais pas ceux qui ont été
assassinés étaient les politiques du
journal il était l'âme de ce journal et
oui ils ont tué charlie je voulais pas
que tignes où ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à huy qui nous la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre pour cette deuxième
partie d'émission nous sommes ensemble
jusqu'à 21h30 tout de suite les titres
de l'actualité de ce jeudi déconfinement
adapté par territoire mais pas par
région distanciation sociale et port du
masque qui sera probablement obligatoire
dans les transports publics
voici les grandes lignes du plan
déconfinement présenté par emmanuel
macron aux élus aujourd'hui edouard
philippe fera le reste la semaine
prochaine de la vigilance toujours
encore plus face aux cordes à virus les
services de renseignement sont
pleinement mobilisées cyber attaques d
information organisée volumes échangés
sur internet
les menaces ne faiblissent pas dans
l'ombre des hommes veille pendant que le
gouvernement organise lui la lutte face
à cette situation inédite de pandémie
c'est des prix du pétrole un négatif à
l'incroyable s'est produit cette semaine
avec est la chute à - 1 37 dollar du
baril de brut américain un plongeon
historique l'excès d'offre sur le marché
est telle que certains sont prêts à
payer pour les débarrassent de leur
production alors comment en est on
arrivé là peut-on l'expliquer par la
seule crise du coronavirus le secteur
pétrolier peut-il sont relevés
autant de questions auxquelles
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre dans un quart d'heure
[Musique]
la france déplore donc près de 22000
décès dus aux coronavirus selon un
nouveau bilan donné par la direction
générale de la santé la hausse de ces
dernières 24 heures est de 516 morts en
léger retrait par rapport à la veille
pour le 15e jour consécutif le nombre de
personnes en réanimation a baissé de 165
patients l elysée annonce que le
déconfinement ne sera pas régionaliser
le port du masque sera quant à lui
obligatoire dans les transports en
commun ce qui concerne le retour à
l'école des élèves il se fera sur la
base du volontariat et depuis la
fermeture en tout cas des établissements
scolaires il y à un mois et demi la
continuité pédagogique ce fait a priori
en ligne quand ça marche
difficile cependant pour certains élèves
de suivre leurs cours à grigny dans
l'essonne stefano miss ancien champion
de france de judo a offert des
ordinateurs pour que les jeunes puissent
continuer d'étudier reportage estelle
farges avec piotr lazare ski dominique
est étudiante en bts banque
bonjour sourire aux lèvres la jeune
femme bien récupérer de quoi étudier
sereinement donné je vais vous demander
de semis en face de votre nom et dont
convenir l'ordinateur qui est offert par
la société ippon
de fait jean bonijol merci c'est très
important parce que j'avais du mal à
suivre des cours j'avais du mal à
travailler un peu ce que travaille avec
le téléphone c'est pas pratique du
coupage l'ordinateur va vraiment m'aider
comme dominique en tout ils sont 105
jeunes recensés par la municipalité de
grigny dans l'essonne à recevoir
gratuitement un ordinateur sans matériel
sans internet pour certains nombreux
sont les collégiens lycéens ou étudiants
s être retrouvé privé d'école
températion en résulte
dans un souci sur la ville dans le cadre
de la continuité éducative on s'est
aperçu que les enfants des quartiers
prioritaires de grigny pour certains
n'avaient pas accès à internet d'où la
difficulté d'avoir une continuité
éducative et de suivre leur scolarité
comme c'est le cas à l'heure actuelle en
allant se en ces temps de confinement et
donc du coup il a fallu qu'on trouve une
solution
la solution est arrivé par cet homme
stéphane nos miss l'ancien champion de
france de judo aujourd'hui chef
d'entreprise a créé une fondation pour
combattre la fracture numérique
notamment en afrique
aujourd'hui c'est donc à grigny là où il
a grandi qu'ils se mobilisent
la fracture numérique allait elle est à
côté de paris même des fois dans paris
et donc j'ai décidé d'aider de reporter
mon action d'afrique sur la france pour
pour bien aider le plus possible
d'enfants qui étaient dans la dans la
précarité scolaire tout part de
l'éducation quoi si les enfants sont
bien éduqués après le la vie allait bien
et mieux tracer quoi et qui soit en
échec
déjà c'est difficile de lui dans les
quartiers et là que tu les retrouves en
est encore plus en échec scolaire à
aider ce coup d'essai carrément
déscolarisés parce que le gamin le gamin
qui a qui cas pas d'ordinateur il est
déscolarisé ça c'est inadmissible en
france à voir les gamins déscolarisés
quoi via sa fondation et son entreprise
stefano miss a aussi lancé une cagnotte
en ligne pour permettre à d'autres
enfants de recevoir un ordinateur
et le coronavirus est bouleversé
d'autres au secteur à travers le monde
comme les renseignements depuis le début
de la crise les services intérieurs et
extérieurs tourne à plein régime en
voici quelques exemples
[Musique]
à
pour en parler nous sommes savait que
gilles sacaze anciens cadres du service
action de la dgse bonsoir gilles sacaze
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france quel rôle selon vous pour les
renseignements ces temps de pandémie est
ce qu ils peuvent être déterminants
d'une manière ou d'une autre
comment m'en tirer les enseignements de
ce ne serait pas concernée je dirais
dans cette dans cette période on a une
catastrophe sanitaire mondiale avec des
enjeux politiques et des enjeux
économiques majeurs je crois que comme
on en a pas eu en gros depuis les
conflits mondiaux
ça ça induit un certain nombre de crises
si vous voulez à la fois sur le plan
international dans la relation entre les
états et vous l'avez évoqué dans vos
dents dans vos titres en termes de pour
arriver je dirais à acheter
prioritairement vous l'exemple italien
était donné les gérer les pénuries de
masques de matériel médical etc
donc il ya des risques de gouvernance
gel de stabilité intérieure parce que
tout et tout est exacerbé en réalité et
de sécurité également intérieur nos
ennemis habituels n'ont pas disparu ils
sont toujours là il certains voient ça a
été annoncé notamment un côté des
islamistes comme l'affaiblissement d'un
certain nombre de pays comme une
opportunité pour pour agir les tensions
sociales également sur la et elles sont
encore une fois que ça servait parce
qu'on a on a des gouvernements s'il
valable en france mais c'est valable
partout qui peuvent être discrédité ou
déstabiliser dans leur gestion de la
crise donc bien sûr les les territoires
perdus on le voit actuellement les
territoires perdus de la république pour
reprendre un peu le
le terme désormais célèbre de georges
bensoussan tous ces problèmes là qui
étaient antérieurs existent ils sont
exacerbées les services s'y intéressait
déjà donc il
ici intéresse d'autant plus fortement
que que les problèmes les problèmes se
sont aggravés par la crise et il ya des
choses qui sont vraiment spécifique à la
crise qu'il faut qu'il faut également
gérer vérifier les informations qui nous
sont bonnes et on a vu avec la chine qui
nous sont données à la fois en termes de
chiffres etc
parce que c'est important pour pour
l'analyse on se rend compte un peu
tardivement que la coopération n'était
pas si fluide que ce qu'on croyait et
est également vérifié vérifier tout ce
qui est en termes de ressources
tout ce qui nous est proposé justement
j'ai le sacaze vous parliez de la chine
on s'est tous dit alors sans regarder
des james bond que les services de
renseignement notamment français
évidemment mais pas qu'eux ont rapporté
1 les événements qui se passait en chine
très tôt pourquoi selon vous ça n'a pas
permis au gouvernement d'anticiper
peut-être mieux la crise je suis patient
enfin je ne sais pas une clique a été la
qualité je dirais des informations je
pense que tous les services occidentaux
on en sort on sous-estimé la capacité
des chinois à retrouver leurs vieux
réflexes sur une crise sanitaire
peut-être sur d'autres sujets on est
plus attentif mais en matière de crise
sanitaire et nous intoxiquer parce que
clairement c'est ce qui s'est passé on a
quand même été intoxiqués pour des
raisons je dirais culturel du culte du
secret je je probablement pour des
raisons également de politique
intérieure donc ce n'était pas forcément
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
c'était pas forcément hostiles au départ
mais l'enjeu maintenant c'est de cesser
la sortie de la crise qui va être
conditionnés par la façon dont on va on
va gérer la crise les ya des pays qui
s'en remettront plus vite que d'autres
des pays qui en sortiront ce
déstabiliser et c'est là que je dirais
les rivalités entre les différents états
entre la la chine entre les etats-unis
la france l'europe on a vu à quel point
la les relations européennes ont été au
sein de l'union européenne ont été
perturbés donc bien sûr tout ça il ya
des enjeux de conquête derrière de
conquête de marché
c'est le comment dire la tentation
d'intoxiquer avant et pendant la crise
les pays concurrents je dirais sans
parler des demis mais les pays
simplement concurrents économiquement
elle elle est grande elle est pas
nouvelle mais elle est celle du rader
souvent il va y avoir d effondrement
économique il ya des enjeux majeurs
il ya des pays qui se relève
difficilement ou très tardivement de
tout ça j'ai fait qu'à sedan vous parlez
des lutins contre la pandémie
on l'a vu dans notre petit clip
les services de renseignements qui
peuvent jouer un rôle notamment dans
dans le traçage des malades
là on n'est pas vraiment tous égaux en
fonction des pays n'est ce pas envoyer
square signant bernard squarcini un
ancien patron des services secrets bien
voilà en france c'est compliqué les
politiques bloc sur ce genre de choses
mais en tout cas c'est
peut-être l'un des rôles des
renseignements se trace thing cette
surveillance des malades
alors il ya il ya il ya déjà il ya comme
on dit il ya un phénomène culturel je
dirais qui est important c'est à dire
que la france c'est pas la chine s'est
pas non plus israël je pense que la
population française accueil globalement
de façon assez négative cette cette
surveillance même moins si vous voulez
qui suis quand même de culture de
renseignements je je je pense qu'il ya
peut-être des urgences il y aujourd'hui
on fournit pas les masques ont fourni
difficilement des tests on est en
difficulté sur les moins maintenant mais
on était au départ de la crise en
difficulté sur sur les lits en
réanimation et on va mettre en place un
outil de traçabilité des malades alors
qu'on sait même pas aujourd'hui on n'est
pas capable de comment dire d'identifier
de tester suffisamment de monde pour
savoir qui est contagieux ou pas donc je
pense qu'il ya un phénomène culturel
mais il ya aussi une gestion des
crédibilité faudrait pas aggraver je
dirais la la crise de gouvernance et
aggraver la crise de confiance
aujourd'hui qu'on convient en france
avec des outils qui m'apparaissent
certainement opportun quand tout le
reste fonctionne aujourd'hui je pense
que on a suffisamment de choses basiques
qui dysfonctionnent pour se concentrer
là dessus
est-ce que c'était presque la façon dont
chaque pays justement gère la pandémie
est très scrutées par les services de
renseignement notamment français oui oui
oui pour les raisons que j'ai évoquées
parce que c'est important de savoir quel
quelques quelles seront les forces et
les faiblesses à la sortie de la crise
des uns et des autres de nos partenaires
mais aussi de nos concurrents il y aura
six des opportunités de marché il ya des
remises en question
profonde qui seront faites j'espère
qu'ils sont fait qu' en tout cas devrait
être fait en terme de souveraineté en
termes de capacité de souveraineté on
l'a vu sur le plan économique vous avez
parlé de la chine
on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui
beaucoup de nous pan de notre économie
dépend de la chine et que on n'a pas
forcément vocation à rester amis en
permanence eux mêmes peuvent vivre une
crise qui les met dans l'incapacité
encore une fois sans même parler
d'austérité qui les met dans
l'incapacité de nous fournir en terme de
capacité de résilience on s'est rendu
compte qu'on a on se rend compte qu'il
ya un certain nombre de choses qu'on
n'est plus capable de faire qu'on n'est
plus dans les caves de tenir à la fois
en termes d'éducation pour les individus
les familles etc
on parlait de stock aujourd'hui la la
norme c zéro stock est ce que on doit
continuer comme ça en termes de
production même de denrées je dirais
sans parler d'autres technologies mais
ne serait-ce que de denrées de première
nécessité
voilà c'est la relation aussi est ce que
est ce que les bonnes relations
d'aujourd'hui le reste en cas de crise
on le voit au sein de l'union européenne
les paris qu'on fait sur l'avenir sur
son important je pense combat on va
remettre en question un certain nombre
de choses et ça va aussi modifier
fortement la relation qu'on peut avoir
avec à l'international merci gilles
sacaze anciens cadres du service action
de la dgse d'avoir été avec nous des
prix du pétrole
négatif l'incroyable s'est donc produit
cette semaine avec la chute à - 37
dollar du baril de brut américain un
plongeon historique l'excès d'offre sur
le marché telles que certains sont prêts
à payer pour qu'on les débarrassent de
leur production alors comment en est on
arrivé là peut-on l'expliquer par la
seule crise du coroner virus le secteur
pétrolier peut-il sont relevées on voit
tout cela avec vous l'économiste jacques
sapir bonsoir jacques bienvenu toujours
avec nous villa skype évidemment jacques
que se passe-t-il sur le marché du
pétrole alors stéphanie comme vous
l'avez dit l'économie l'épidémie du duc
au vide 19 et surtout le confinement des
principales économies
a eu un impact direct sur le marché du
pétrole avec une chute très brutale de
la demande mais ce n'est pas la seule
explication au jour extraordinaire que
nous venons de vivre parce que au-delà
de ce que j'appelle le corona craque
c'est à dire ce krach pétroliers sur
fond de coronavirus et bien nous avons
trois pays qui sont en train de
s'affronter sur le marché du pétrole il
ya là amis saoudite la russie et les
etats unis
et cet affrontement a eu un rôle
déterminant dans ce qui vient de se
passer
alors jacques a tout d'abord une
question simple comment un bien matériel
comme le pétrole peut-il avoir un prix
négatif
il faut nous expliquer car on a parfois
du mal à y croire vous avez tout à fait
raison c'est fini tout d'abord il faut
rappeler que quand on parle du prix du
pétrole
c'est en réalité une simplification il y
à des prix du pétrole alors
essentiellement il y en a deux banques
fait y en a plus mais disons-le y en a
deux qui sont principaux qui servent un
petit peu de prix directeur le brent
pour le marché du pétrole qui est à
londres et le west texas intermediate le
double ou taille comme on dit
dont le marché est aux états unis
l'épisode des prix négatifs s'est
produit sur le double outillage et pas
sur le brent alors en plus il faut
savoir que les marchés du pétrole sont
ce que l'on appelle des marchés au futur
on achète par exemple une quantité de
pétrole en mars ou en avril pour être
livrés physiquement au début du mois de
mai alors jacquet qu'est ce que cela
veut dire de l'état de la demande aux
états unis par exemple
alors ce qui s'est passé et c'est fini
c'est qu'avec la baisse de la demande
les acheteurs ont cherché des réservoirs
pour stocker le pétrole qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas utiliser dans l'immédiat
or pratiquement toutes les capacités de
stockage sont aujourd'hui soit utilisés
soit loué et en particulier à
l'extrémité de l'oléoduc de l'oklahoma
où se font justement
les transactions sur le double ou tient
alors les gérer les acheteurs ont
cherché désespérément à se débarrasser
des quantités de pétrole qui ne
pouvaient plus stockées et c'est cela
qui a provoqué justement cet
effondrement des prix et comme le marché
est ce qu'on appelle un marché aux
futurs les acheteurs ont cherché à
revendre les quantités qu'ils avaient
acquise provoquant ainsi des ventes à
perte comme on dit dans le jargon
ils ont vendu short et ce sont ses
ventes à pertes qui ont entraîné le prix
au dessous de zéro alors il faut
comprendre que cet épisode est largement
le fait tout d'abord d'une pénurie de
moyens de stockage mais aussi d'un
affolement spéculatifs sur ta marché au
futur alors jacques on comprend mieux
effectivement comment on a pu arriver à
des prix négatifs mais ce que c'est
aussi le signe que la demande s'est
effondrée
et oui évidemment stephenie et si l'on
compare les courbes des prix on voit
bien que ces dernières qui était au
dessus de 60 dollars le baril commence à
baisser à partir de la deuxième
quinzaine de janvier quand la chine se
décide en fine et sa population
mais ce que l'on voit aussi sur les
courbes c'est que à partir du 6 mars la
baisse commence à s'accélérer et c'est
ceci qui nous indique que l'épidémie
ducobu 19 n'est pas la seule responsable
de cette baisse des prix
et que s'est-il passé jacques le 6 mars
alors le 6 mars nous avions à vienne en
autriche
une réunion des pays de l'opep à
laquelle était invité la russie
c'est ce que l'on appelle d'ailleurs le
format opep plus big l'opep plus la
russie
cette réunion avait pour but de discuter
de nouvelles baisses de production pour
tenter justement de faire remonter les
cours
quand le ministre du pétrole russe
monsieur novak est d'arriver à vienne
il a déclaré qu'il était impensable que
de nouvelles mesures
reçoit décidé tant que les états unis
qui sont devenus et ça c'est un
changement important depuis une dizaine
d'années qui sont devenu un exportateur
de poids avec leur pétrole de schiste ne
prendrai pas leur part justement dans
ces baisses de production l'arabie
saoudite a alors dénoncé les accords
existants et décider de pompey autant de
pétrole que possible afin de gagner des
parts de marché et c'est cela qui a
provoqué ce qu'il faut bien appeler une
espèce de guerre des prix au moment où
justement la demande mondiale se
réduisait de près d'un tiers sur fond de
crise du coronavirus et c'est cela
jacques qui a provoqué le plongeon des
prix oui c'est fait c'est cela qui a
provoqué le plongeon des prix le prix
calculé sur l' indice américain sur le
wti est passé rapidement sous la barre
des 30 dollars
les jours suivants le brun a suivi mais
en décalé et c'est cette baisse des prix
qui a provoqué une véritable crise alors
c'est aussi une crise industrielle aux
etats unis
mais jacques pourquoi précisément aux
états unis eh bien ces familles il faut
regarder le coût d'extraction des coûts
de production du pétrole de schiste aux
états unis
ce conte moyen varie de 23 à 36 dollars
le baril seulement voilà c'est une
moyenne
et pour de nombreuses petites et
moyennes compagnies le prix se situe
plutôt entre 45 et 50 dollars le baril
alors pris de lundi ce double utile qui
est inférieur à 30 dollars de très
nombreuses petites compagnies qui sont
en général ou redemande été fait
faillite
d'ailleurs dès le début du mois d'avril
près d'un travailleur sur deux de
l'industrie pétrolière américaine a été
licencié avec un prix inférieur à 20 $
ce qui est la situation actuelle même
largement en dessous par moments de ces
22 là c'est tout le secteur qui est
sinistré et c'est pourquoi
donald rhin a décidé de lancer un
programme spécial de soutien à
l'industrie du pétrole et du gaz et
qu'ils envisagent même
d'interdire les importations de pétrole
aux états unis
alors on peut penser à chaque
logiquement que cette chute des prix
fait également malo aux autres
producteurs
oui évidemment stéphanie la russie par
exemple dont le pétrole est rattachée à
lundi ce brain s'ouvre mais elle souffre
moins que les autres ne serait ce que
parce que son budget était calculée sur
un prix assez bas sur un prix de 40
dollars le baril et quelle à d'amples
aux réserves de change et il faut bien
le dire un système fiscal qui est très
protecteur pour les compagnies
pétrolières
néanmoins elle souffre aussi et puis il
faut parler de l'arabie saoudite qui est
certainement le pays qui aujourd'hui est
celui qui souffre financièrement le plus
et c'est pour ça que les pays de l'opep
plus ont décidé finalement de réduction
importante de la production pour environ
10 millions de barils par jour alors est
ce que cela sera suffisant
non c'est fait non il faudra aller plus
loin
surtout il faudrait que les etats unis
eux aussi acceptent de s'engager dans un
cadre contraignant alors il faut dire
qu'il s'y prépare d'ailleurs car la
production a baissé d'environ 4 millions
de barils par jour rien qu'aux états
unis
alors jacques selon vous est-ce qu'un
accord est possible bien stéphanie un
nouvel accord est en réalité inévitable
même si on ne sait pas encore sous
quelle forme se manifestera quelle forme
il prendra les états unis n'ont guère
d'autre choix que de se coordonner avec
leurs adversaires d'hier
il faut bien dire que l'abe de ce point
de vue là la leçon a porté le marché du
pétrole va donc se réorganiser et cette
réorganisation se fera d'ailleurs en
parallèle avec le déconfinement des
grandes économies
il est clair que ça va prendre du temps
mais cette réorganisation est à terme
inévitable
merci jacques pensée explications et
cette analyse de la crise des prix du
pétrole et à bientôt sur rt france merci
à vous
et pour terminer ce journal petit tour
d'horizon en plusieurs pays ont mis en
place des solutions innovantes certaines
villes optent pour des bracelets
intelligent d'autres font appel à la
médecine traditionnelle dans la lutte
contre le corps anna virus regarder
[Musique]
nous utilisons 3 4 à 5 plan dans la
chambre de désinfection qui sont
l'eucalyptus lemire à ouïr halak a beau
me voir la cannelle et le romarin
[Musique]
saleh doit y avoir maculé de sang sort
le bracelet possède plusieurs capteurs
qui reconnaissent la position du poignet
dans l'espace le processus de calibrage
enregistre certaines positions de la
main qui sont compatibles avec le
comportement de contact faciale cette
position dans l'espace est défini avec
une fenêtre de tolérance par l'appareil
génère un signal vivre au tactile
lorsqu'elle est détectée
[Musique]
à vélo
ces flics en outre la lumière
ultraviolette est appliqué à des doses
mesurées par nos ingénieurs
universitaires ce qui permet de détruire
raisonnablement les particules virales
et bactériennes ce qui nous permet
surtout de réutiliser des masques
notamment ceux qui ont été fabriqués
dans les maisons des relocalisations
ok bien fabriqué à la maca
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission un peu
écourtée vous le savez en raison de la
crise du coronavirus qui nous pousse à
nous adapter
prochain point sur l'actualité demain
matin 8 heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]
depuis le début de cette crise les
français sont dans le flou avec des
informations contradictoires
quelles en sont les conséquences
psychologiquement la peur quand même
socio économique c'est à dire qu'il ya
quand même une détresse socio économique